foreign
if there's one thing the absolute worst
elements of our society depend on maybe
more than anything else it's that the
majority of sane people have a lot going
on in their lives you know they have
jobs families Hobbies they can't keep
track of every big Scandal they hear
about on television and uh follow it for
years to figure out how it turned out
they don't have the time to do that even
if they wanted to and that's a boon in
particular to the modern media because
they know that they can invent whatever
lies they want in order to whip millions
of people into a frenzy
by the time the truth comes out most
people have moved on with their lives
they've already voted in whatever
election was coming up they certainly
won't demand Mass firings of all the
editors and reporters who lied to them
won't even remember their names and if
you doubt that try to recall just as an
example who exactly told you that
Michael Brown was a good kid who had his
hands up yelling don't shoot when a
white supremacist police officer in
Ferguson Missouri shot him for no reason
can you name any news anchor or
journalists specifically who who said
that
of course you can I mean they all did
but like what's one particular one it's
impossible to single someone out because
the entirety of the corporate media was
telling the same lie in unison for six
months
and then after all that time and after a
wave of deadly riots the Obama doj was
forced to admit that actually this good
kid was not executed in the middle of
the street for no reason and oh yeah he
didn't have his hands up in surrender
either in reality he had charge of the
police officer assaulting him and trying
to take his gun
and he did that after he roughed up a
store owner and stole some some cigars
did any of that extra context matter
though
to this day college kids still Gather in
the street yelling hands up don't shoot
in honor of Michael Brown
it's not just BLM enforcers in antifa
who say that a lot of normal everyday
people have the same totally inaccurate
view of what happened
what's uh unspoken here what what no one
dares to say in the media regardless of
partisan affiliation
is who the actual victims of these
charades are now on the right you'll
occasionally hear people talk about you
know Michael Brown and his crimes and
how he wasn't really a victim but the
name Darren Wilson is usually ignored in
those conversations he's the police
officer who happens to be white who
spotted Michael Brown walking in the
Middle Street nearly a decade ago he's
the cop Michael Brown started punching
without any provocation
how's Darren Wilson doing these days
no one seems to know or care his lawyer
said that he had to go into hiding he
could never be a police officer again
there aren't many recent updates on
Darren Wilson's life on the internet
these days he's just disappeared his
life was destroyed
and that was that
the term scapegoat comes from the
ancient Hebrew practice of casting an
actual literal goat out into the
Wilderness as a symbol of the sins of
the people and casting out the sin we
are we are um you know laying all the
sins upon this animal casting it out
it's an old religious practice that's
still carried out today except in our
culture we find random white people like
Darren Wilson to be exiled or destroyed
as atonement for white sins specifically
and oftentimes the scapegoat is
Vindicated by the facts later on but it
doesn't really matter because the
specific facts were never important to
the Mob and the people demanding this
person's head
doesn't matter what they did
or what they didn't do
it matters what they represent
maybe you recall this story from a few
years back in the late afternoon
um
in late afternoon several years ago it
was back in 2018. two black men walked
into a Starbucks in Philadelphia and
they asked to use the bathroom
but the staff told them that the
bathroom was for customers only and
that's a pretty common policy especially
in Philadelphia because you don't want
junkies shooting up in your bathroom I
mean that's why they have these that's
why they lock the bathrooms that's why
they say you have to be a customer to
use the bathroom
but the two men didn't buy anything they
just sat down and refused to make a
purchase after that went on for a while
and uh you know one of the staff members
came up to them told me I had to make a
purchase or leave
again it's a reasonable request because
Starbucks is not a homeless shelter okay
it's not it's not just a lounge you know
to go hang out in
but the men refused to take either
option so the Starbucks worker called
the police
eventually the police arrived and they
did exactly what they're supposed to do
they removed the trespassers watch
um
[Music]
there's a guy in that Clipper keeps
asking what did they do which of course
helped the whole incident to go viral
and it went massively viral at the time
after all you know if a random guy in
the viral video doesn't understand
something then it must be outrageous
but it really wasn't that hard to
understand these two men walked on the
private property they refused to buy
anything and when they were asked to
leave they refused it's called
trespassing otherwise known as a crime
in a world filled with uncertainties
it's crucial to be ready for whatever
comes your way whether it's a natural
disaster a sudden emergency or
unforeseen circumstances having a
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the assurance
that you and your loved ones will be
well taken care of right now my Patriot
Supply is knocking 200 off their popular
three-month emergency food kit to help
you start growing your supply today go
to preparewithwalsh.com and grab this
special price before it ends your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in essential
situations you can enjoy a wide variety
of my paychecks apply food from
buttermilk pancakes and chicken alfredo
to rice pudding their meals have you
covered for every part of your day and
the best part is each meal is actually
delicious so don't wait for disaster to
strike before taking action invest in
your safety and well-being by securing
your food storage they go to prepare
with walsh.com and save 200 on each kit
that your family will need an emergency
go to preparewithwalsh.com right now
that's prepared with walsh.com Congress
once again allowed itself to be pushed
into appeasing the administration and
raising the debt ceiling for the 79th
time Paving the way for continued
Reckless spending and further
devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you could do that with the help
of Birch gold the who I buy my gold from
so so do thousands of other concern
Savers as well Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira of 401k into an
IRA in Gold you don't pay a penny out of
pocket it's that simple when currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar even have protect
your savings with gold Birch gold is an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau and thousands of happy customers
you can find out why by texting Walsh to
989898 to get your free info kit on gold
again text Walsh to 989898
but when there's a moral Panic underway
laws don't apply anymore apparently and
that all really depends on your skin
color so social media was full of posts
proclaiming that this was proof that
white supremacy is Alive and Well the
United States one of the most viral
video one of the most viral tweets about
this episode which got more than a
hundred thousand likes read this way
quote America is a place where a black
man has a greater chance of being
arrested for going to Starbucks than a
white man who commits treason in front
of the entire world
protesters the games began screaming
about racism in the Starbucks store
where this all went down as they were
flooding into the store and this went on
for days
[Applause]
now instead of standing up to this
Insanity as expected you know Starbucks
uh well is expected they would not stand
up to it I mean Starbucks CEO Kevin
Johnson closed all the company's stores
in the U.S and Canada like all the
stores because of this for racial bias
training he also declared that bathrooms
and Starbucks henceforth would be open
to anyone paying customers or not
junkies can sit on the toilet and shoot
up all they want
Kevin Johnson later went on CNBC to brag
about how well he handled the situation
uh and in the kiss of death Jim Cramer
praised him for it watch
talk about crisis talk about the way you
handle it because I think when we look
back in the textbooks it's going to be
the way you have to handle something
that is antithetical to everything you
believe in well first of all Jim you
know you gotta you gotta say that when I
saw the video of the the two gentlemen
who were arrested in our store it was
heartbreaking but I knew at that moment
that uh you know as the CEO of the
company I'm accountable and we've got to
show up I've got to show up and so
getting to Philadelphia being on the
ground and talking to everyone that I
could talk to and learn from and
understand why this happened how this
could happen and then take action to
ensure that it never happens again now
we're proud of the actions we've taken
you know we closed our stores for the
afternoon on May 29th we did the first
round of training every month we're
continuing to drop new training modules
to to our stores and it has made us a
better company it has allowed us to
actually Elevate the customer experience
in our stores
from the point of view of seeing a lot
of CEOs address an issue you got in
front of it obviously if Jim CR Jim
Cramer is praising something it's going
to collapse very quickly and Starbucks
response to this whole episode which Jim
Cramer loved did just that about a month
after this incident Starbucks decided to
fire an employee named Shannon Phillips
who is Shannon Phillips well she was a
regional manager in charge of 13
Starbucks locations in and around
Philadelphia she was not the store
manager in charge of location where this
incident happened but Shannon Phelps was
fired anyway why well here's what
Shannon Phillips alleged in her lawsuit
against Starbucks she says that the
company quote took steps to punish white
employees who had not been involved in
the arrests but who worked in and around
the city of Philadelphia in an effort to
convince the community that it had
properly responded to the incident
so Starbucks just looked for a white
person to fire is what they did Phillip
said that Starbucks told her to punish a
white employee for PR purposes uh you
know for just made up reasons and when
Phillips refused they fired her
they kept the black employee who ran the
store at the center of this incident
like the actual store manager was black
and they kept him but they can the
regional manager
now as you may have heard Phillips just
won a 25 million dollar wrongful
termination lawsuit against Starbucks
she proved that they discriminated
against her because she was a white
person who was offered as a sacrificial
victim just like Darren Wilson
um and just like so many others in her
case she was Vindicated she got some
restitution but that's rarely how these
things play out and by the way just to
put a bow on this whole farce last year
Starbucks reversed its Open Door
bathroom policy according to the
Philadelphia Inquirer quote Starbucks is
modifying its open bathroom policy that
allows anyone to use the restroom at its
stores employees now have the option to
close bathrooms if there are safety
concerns
in other words actually Starbucks still
doesn't want junkies shooting up in
their bathrooms you know they allowed it
for a few years
um in order to Virtue signal and they
realized that no this is actually
terrible you know this is why we don't
want this
maybe the manager who called the cops
five years ago was right after all who
would have thought
that case is notable because it's so
rare you almost never see Vindication
for the sacrificial lands in any of
these cases certainly you don't see
restitution
you know you don't see legal Vindication
anyway
and you almost never see laws against
racism applying to actual racists you
know indiscriminately in this way
instead you see what's happening to
Daniel Penny who's the Good Samaritan
restrained of violent lunatic on the New
York subway we finally heard his full uh
his full side of the story a few days
ago which we played on the show at the
time now keep in mind Daniel penny is is
taking a major Risk by speaking out most
defense attorneys tell their clients and
I don't know if this happened with
Daniel Penny but I would assume it did
tell their clients to stay silent and
plead the Fifth
um that's because even if you're
innocent it's easy to slip up and say
something the prosecutor can use in
court to make the case that you're
guilty so it tells us a lot that Daniel
Penny like Kyle Rittenhouse is
disregarding those risks he knows what's
you know he knows what happened he knows
the truth he was listening to music on
his headphones minding his own business
with Jordan Neely a vagrant with dozens
of arrests including one for punching a
senior citizen actually a couple of uh
senior citizen assaults began doing
exactly what you would expect of a baker
to punches senior citizens he was
threatening to kill passengers he was
saying that he was he wasn't afraid to
go to jail he wasn't afraid to die
penny a marine then restrained Neely
with the help of another passenger
making sure he could breathe and that's
when Neely who according to his family
was taking mind-altering synthetic drugs
to treat depression died
it's clear now as if it wasn't clear
already that Penny was not only in the
right but in fact acting heroically
and we also know that
much of what was originally claimed
about the caves especially that Penny
choked Neely for 15 minutes was a lie
the actual incident went on for just a
few minutes like five minutes
but in spite of all those facts which
aren't even in dispute a grand jury just
this week indicted Daniel penny
he becomes yet another and a long line
of scapegoats
who happened to share the same skin
color
at a certain point you have to take a
step back and recognize that the
specifics of all these incidents again
don't matter to the Mob
no one cares that Michael Brown never
said hands up don't shoot no one cares
if the two black men in the Starbucks
were trespassing no one cares that
Jordan Neely was threatening to kill
people all that matters is that Darren
Wilson Janet Phillips and Daniel Penny
have the wrong skin color
at least that's all that matters to the
social media mob to the media uh to the
biggest corporations in the country
to the justice system in so many cases
we see it again and again
and too many incidents to mention
and they're not worried that Shannon
Phillips won 25 million dollars they
think her case is the exception that
proves the rule which is that there are
no consequences for lying in the most
base and unethical ways possible
what's hopeful What suggests that they
might be very mistaken is that these
sacrificial Lambs aren't just going into
hiding anymore
Darren Wilson had to disappear nearly a
decade ago that's how powerful the mob
was people like Daniel Penny they're not
hiding he's going in front of cameras
telling everyone what really happened
even in Alvin Bragg's New York you know
of all places he's doing that
right now this is not the norm but if
Daniel Penny wins as Shannon Phillips
did uh that could change in a hurry once
the racehawk stirs and the outrage
Merchants know that their targets aren't
going to Simply back down and that
people will remember what happened to
them
then those people start to lose their
power
and obviously that can happen soon
enough but in the meantime those race
hucksters and outrage Merchants are of
course today canceled
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts